what i want to do in this video is
establish a reasonably
powerful condition in which we can
establish that a
vector field or that a line integral of
a vector field is path independent
and when i say that i mean that let's
say i were to take this line integral
along the path c of f
dot dr and let's say
my path looks like this let's say my
path looks like this
that's my x and y axis y
and x and let's say my path looks
something like this
i start there and i go over there
to point c just like or to the my end
point the curve here
is c and so i would evaluate this line
integral this vector field
along this path this would be
a path independent vector field or we
call that a conservative
vector field if
if this thing is equal to
the same integral the same integral
over a different path that has the same
endpoints so let's call this c1 so this
is c1
and this is c2 this vector field is
conservative
if if i start at the same point but i
take a different path let's say i go
something like that if i take a
different path
and this is my c2 i still get the same
value
these integrals what's this telling me
is that all it cares about to evaluate
these integrals
is my starting point and my ending point
it doesn't care what i do in between it
doesn't care
how i get from my starting point to my
end point these two
these two integrals have the same start
point and same end point so irregardless
of their actual path
they're going to be the same that's what
it means for f
to be a conservative field or what or
what it means to be
for this integral to be path independent
so before i prove or i show you the
conditions let's build up our
toolkit a little bit and so you may have
or may or n
you may or may not have already seen the
multi-variable chain rule
multi-variable
chain rule and i'm not going to prove it
in this video
but i think it'll be pretty intuitive
for you so maybe it doesn't need to have
a proof or i'll prove it eventually but
i really just want to give you the
intuition
and all that says is that if i have some
function let's say i have
f of x and y but x and y are then
functions of
let's say a third variable t so f of x
of t and y of t
that the derivative of f with respect to
t
the derivative of f with respect
to t that is multivariable i have two
variables here in x and y this is going
to be equal to
the partial of f with respect to x how
fast does
f change as x changes times
the derivative of x with respect to t
this is a
single variable function right here so
you just can take you can take a regular
derivative
so times how fast x changes
with respect to t this is a standard
derivative this is partial derivative
because at that level we're dealing with
two variables and we're not done
plus how fast f changes with respect to
y
how fast the partial of f with respect
to y
times the derivative of y with respect
to t
so d y d t
i'm not going to prove it but i think it
makes pretty good intuition
this is saying as i move a little bit dt
how much of a df do i get or how fast
does f change with respect to t
it says well there's two ways that f can
change it can change with respect to x
and it can change with respect to y
so why don't i add those two things
together as they are both
changing with respect to t that's all
it's saying and if you kind of
imagined that you could cancel out this
partial x with this dx and this partial
y with this d y
you could have kind of imagined the
partial of f with respect to t
on the x side of things and then plus
the partial
of f with respect to t on the y in the y
dimension and then that will give you
the total change of f with respect to t
kind of a hand wavy argument there but
at least to me this makes oh
this is a pretty intuitive formula so
that's our toolkit right there the
multi-variable chain rule
we're going to put that aside for a
second now
let's say i have some vector field
f and this is different than this f so
i'll do it in a different color magenta
i have some vector field f that is a
function
of x and y and let's say that it happens
to be
the gradient of some scalar field
let's say it equals the gradient of
some scalar field i'll call that capital
f and this is gradient which means and
this is you know capital f
is also a function of x and y so i could
write you know i could write
f is also let me write it i don't want
to write it on a new line
i could also write up here capital f is
also a function of
x and y and the gradient all that means
is
that f the the vector field f of x y
lowercase f of x y is equal to the
partial derivative of
uppercase f with respect to
x times the i unit vector plus
the partial of uppercase f with respect
to y
times the j unit vector this is the
definition of the gradient right here
this is the definition of a gradient and
if you imagine that
uppercase f is some type of surface so
if
uppercase f is some type of surface like
that
just trying to do my so this is
uppercase f
of xy the gradient of
f of xy is going to be a vector field
that tells you the direction of steepest
ascent at any point
so it will be defined on the x y plane
so on the x y plane it'll tell you so
let me draw that's the vertical axis
maybe that's the x axis that's the y
axis
so the gradient of it if you so if you
take any point on the xy plane it'll
tell you the direction you need to
travel to go into the steepest descent
and for this gradient field it's going
to be something like this
it's going to be something like this and
maybe over here it starts going in that
direction because you
would descend towards this little
minimum point right here anyway i don't
want to get too involved in that and the
whole point of this
isn't to really get the intuition behind
gradients
there are other videos on this the point
of this is to get a a
test to see whether something is path
independent whether a vector field is
path independent whether it's
conservative
and it turns out that if this exists
and i'm going to prove it now if this
exists
if f is the gradient of some scalar
field
if f is equal to the gradient of some
scalar field then
then f is conservative
conservative or you could say it doesn't
matter what path we follow when we take
a line integral
over f it just matters about our
starting point
and our ending point now let me see if i
can
prove that to you so i'm let's start
with the assumption that
f can be written this way as the
gradient of
that lowercase f can be written as the
gradient of some
uppercase f so in that case
in that case our integral
our integral let's see well let's let's
let's define our path first so our
position vector function we always need
one of those to do a line integral or a
vector line integral
r of t is going to be equal to
x of t times i plus
y of t times j for
t going between a and b we've seen this
multiple times
this is the definition of this is just a
very general definition of pretty much
any path
in two dimensions and then we're going
to say f
f is going to be f of
x y is going to be equal to this it's
going to be the partial derivative
of uppercase f with respect to x so
we're saying we're assuming that this
exists that this is true
respect times i plus the partial of
uppercase f with respect to y
times j now given this
given this what is
what is f
lowercase f lowercase f dot
d r going to equal over this path right
here this path is divided by this
position function right there well it's
going to be equal to
well we need to get we need to figure
out what dr is and we've done that in
multiple videos i'll do that on the
right over here
dr we've seen it multiple times i'll
just
actually i'll solve it out again dr dt
by definition was equal to dx
dt is equal to dx dt
times i plus d y
d i don't know why i got all fat like
that d
y d t times j
that's what d r d dt is so if we want to
figure out what dr
is the differential dr if we want to
play with differentials in this way
multiply both sides times
dt and actually i'm going to treat dt is
well i'll multiply it i'll distribute it
it's dx
dt times dti
plus dy dt
times dt j so if we're taking the dot
product
of f of f with dr what are we going to
get
what are we going to get we are going to
get and this is let me
so we're going to take so this is going
to be the integral
over the curve over the curve
from i'll write the c right there we
could write it in terms of the endpoints
of t
once we feel good that we have we have
everything in terms of t
but it's going to be equal to this dot
that which is equal to
the partial i'll try to stay color
consistent the partial of
uppercase f with respect to x
times that times dx
dt i'm going to write this dt in a
different color
times dt plus
plus the partial of uppercase f
with respect to y
times this times we're multiplying the j
components right we take the dot product
multiply the i components and then add
that to
what you get from the product of the j
component so this j component is partial
of uppercase f
with respect to y and then we have times
let me switch to a yellow
d y d t times
that dt right over there times that dt
over there
and then we can factor out the dt
we could factor out the dt or actually
just so i don't have to even write it
again
right now i wrote it without well let me
write it again so this is equal to
this is equal to the integral and let's
say we have it in terms of t
we've written everything in terms of t
so where t goes from a
to b and so this is going to be equal to
i write in blue the partial of uppercase
f with respect to x times dx
dt plus i'm distributing this dt out
plus
the partial of uppercase f with respect
to y
d y dt all of that
times dt
this is equivalent to that now
you might realize why i talked about the
multi-variable chain rule
what is this right here what is that
right there
you do some pattern matching that is the
same thing
as the the derivative of uppercase f
with respect to t
look at this let me let me copy and
paste this just so you appreciate it so
let me
copy and paste that copy it
and then let me paste it
so this is our definition or this is our
i want to say definition one can
actually prove it you don't have to
start from there
but this is our multivariable chain rule
right here right the derivative of any
function with respect to t is the
partial of that function with respect to
x times dx dt
plus the partial of that function with
respect to y d y d t i have the partial
of uppercase f with respect to x dx dt
plus the partial of uppercase f with
respect to y do
this and this identical if you just
replace this lowercase f with an
uppercase f
so this in blue right here so this whole
expression is equal to
the integral from a to b t is equal to a
to t is equal to b of of
in blue here the derivative
regular derivative of f with respect to
t dt and how do you eval let me write
the dt in green
how do you evaluate something like this
i just want to make a point this
is just this from the multivariable
chain rule
and how do you evaluate a definite
integral right this will you take the
anti-derivative of the inside
with respect to dt so what is this going
to be equal to
you take the anti-derivative of the
inside the anti-derivative of the inside
that's just df
oh sorry that's just f so this is equal
to f
of t and let me be clear let me be clear
here we wrote before that
f is a function so our uppercase f
is a function of x and y which are
which could also be written since each
of these are functions of t of
could be written as f of x of t of
y of t i'm just rewriting it in
different ways and this could be just
written as
f of t this is the same thing as f of t
these are all equivalent depending on
whether you want to include the x's and
the y's only or the t's only or them
both they're
because both of the x's and y's are
functions of
t so this is the derivative of f with
respect to t
if this was just in terms of t this is
the derivative of that with respect to t
we take its antiderivative we're left
just with f
and we have to evaluate it from t
is equal to a to t is equal to b and so
this
is equal to and this is the home stretch
this is equal to
f of b minus
f of a and if you want to think about it
in this term these terms this is the
same thing
this is equal to f of x of b
y of b let me make sure i got all the
parentheses
minus f of x of a
y of a these are equivalent you give me
any point on the x y plane an x and a y
and it tells me where i am this is my
capital f
it gives me a height just like that but
what this tells me this is a value this
associates a value with every point on
the x y
plane but what it what what this this
whole exercise
remember this is the same thing as that
this is our whole thing that we were
trying to prove that is equal to
f dot d r f dot d r our vector field
which is the gradient of the capital f
remember f
f was equal to the gradient of f we
assume that it's the gradient of some
function capital f if that is the case
then we just did a little bit of
calculus or algebra whatever you want to
call it
and we found that we can evaluate this
integral by taking
by evaluating capital f at t is equal to
b
and then subtracting from that capital f
at t is equal to a
but what that tells you is this integral
the value of this integral
is only is is only dependent
is only dependent at our starting point
t
is equal to a this is the point x
of a y of a and the ending point t
of b x of or t is equal to b which is x
of b
y of b this that integral is only
dependent on these two values how do i
know that
because to solve it i just because i'm
saying that this thing exists
i just had to evaluate that thing at
both those two points i didn't care
about the curve in between
so this shows this shows that if
if f is equal to the gradient this is
often called a potential function
of capital f although they're usually
the negative of each other but it's the
same idea
if the vector field f is the gradient of
some
scalar field uppercase f then
then we can say that f is conservative
f is conservative or
that the integral the line integral of f
dot dr
is path independent it doesn't matter
what path we go on as long as our
starting
and ending points are the same hopefully
you found that useful and we'll do some
examples with that and actually in the
next video
i'll prove another interesting outcome
based on this one